okay so after watching marvel's eternals
one thing becomes clear thanos was right
just in the same way that the return of
the jedi was the empire strikes back of
the star wars saga marvel's eternals is
the avengers endgame of the mcu what now
what i mean by that is that it brings
characters together after a big breakup
in order to save a life as we know it
the movie is also filled with a lot of
lore and in it we discover that the life
cycle of a celestial involves planning a
seed within a planet so that it can grow
along with the intelligent life there
upon reaching a certain point the
celestial will be able to go out into
the galaxy and this birthing process
will destroy the entire planet that
carried it in wiping out half of all
life in the universe thanos somewhat
delayed the destruction of earth and he
no doubt saved countless other planets
who were doomed to the same fate but did
he know well throughout this video we're
going to be discussing the character's
comic book origins what he does in the
mcu and whether we can gather if the
character knew about it or not and if he
did was he actually the true hero
probably not probably but we'll get into
it now if you think thanos knew then
please hit the thumbs up button and if
you don't then the dislike is there as
well also make sure you subscribe to the
channel as we do videos like this every
day and we'd love to have you around
without the way welcome to the heavy
spoilers show i'm your host paul aka the
guy who doesn't do things by half now
let's get into the video
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is thanos's plan as a whole and
one of the big criticisms surrounding it
when infinity war first came out many
people rightly said that he could have
just doubled resources in the universe
and this would have helped problems like
overpopulation without ending any lives
however if we look at the celestials
namely how they emerge from flourishing
planets then saving lives wouldn't stop
them and doubling resources would have
just sped up their growth instead of
delaying it so if thanos did know then
it makes sense that he would have
carried out the snap that was heard
around the universe now though thanos's
origin story is a bit murky we can put
together bits and pieces from the comics
and films in order to sort of give a
rough overview of his early life the
hints towards whether he knew or not in
this source material thanos was born on
titan and he was the son of the eternal
a-laws and susan as we learn in the
post-credits scene of the eternals his
brother was indeed eros who is going to
be played by harry styles growing up
thanos could see the planet was going in
one direction due to overpopulation and
he suggested that they carry out
genocide and destroy half of all life
there in order to save the other half he
was shunned because of this and banished
from the planet but his prophecy came
true and titan ended up becoming a
barren wasteland now the next thing i
want to address is whether thanos is
actually an eternal or not there are
several possibilities and the first is
that he is indeed one which would make
him a highly advanced machine the second
is that he's the son of an eternal and
though it's very difficult for them to
have kids it isn't impossible if thanos
is the child of an eternal then that
would make him an eternal too and this
would mean that he'd also carry the same
difficulty in having offspring
throughout the mcu we see that he adopts
children instead of having them the
old-fashioned way so it seems that he
may not have had this knowledge due to
his home being destroyed this would also
explain why he has a brother and no it
may just be an adopted one the other
characteristics of thanos seem to cement
that he is indeed an eternal every time
that nebula failed he also added more
machine parts to her and potentially
this could be because he himself knows
firsthand that synthetic beings are very
powerful now not only does he have an
extremely long lifespan he's also one of
the most powerful beings in the entire
universe which is why he's able to hold
an infinity stone without dying and
perform the snap thanos also has strange
markings on his skin which in retrospect
look a lot like the glyphs that the
eternals have potentially showing that
he is indeed connected now in the comics
he carried a deviant gene within him
that made him look like he'd fell out of
the ugly tree and hit every branch on
the way down
it's inaudible
that the celestials also created the
deviants and it is possible that they
reused some of the same genetic
programming to create the machines which
may have copied across certain elements
so things like this could happen i think
that the line about eros and thanos
being related was purposely put in the
movie for a reason and to me it does
seem like this was acknowledged to show
that he's also an eternal now moving on
from that if thanos is an eternal then
it's likely that he either found out
from his father or through his own
discoveries exactly what the celestial
plan was in infinity war there are
several clues towards this being the
case and the first is the state of titan
itself and one thing that always bugged
me when watching infinity war is that
the axis of the planet was slightly off
and that this had caused a shift in its
gravity if the planet had become
overpopulated and everyone starved then
that wouldn't change the rotation of
titan and it would have kept its
original gravity something like this
could have only happened if there was a
big shift of the planet that threw it
off its axis say like the birth of a
celestial now it could also be that this
was caused by a war on titan which may
have been hinted at in the opening of
loki but again that doesn't really have
much to do with overpopulation the other
hints towards this come from lines of
dialogue that thanos says and firstly he
states that he's cursed with knowledge
retroactively this could be used in
clickbait fan theory videos to hammer
home the point that he discovered the
truth about the celestials he also said
that when his planet was faced with
extinction that he offered salvation the
extinction could have come from the
birth of a celestial and his plan to
kill off half of the population would
have stopped this now this would also
add to why he traveled to other planets
with intelligent life and wiped out half
of the people there so that this would
stop the growth of a celestial
celestials need intelligent life in
order to flourish and it would make
sense why would target places like
gamora's home now after carrying out the
snap thanos retreated to the garden
which if he knew about the celestial's
plan would make the perfect place to
relax as we learn an avengers endgame
it's pretty much abandoned in terms of
people and all that there are are
animals and crops now this could be
because he was wanting to go somewhere
that no one could be like hey bro you
killed my bro bro but it would also mean
the planet would be a long way off from
a celestial bursting out of it thanos
also destroyed the stone so that the
work couldn't be undone and this pretty
much showed that he knew it was the best
solution to handle things thanos likely
worried that if someone did manage to
blip everyone back that it would start
the cycle again and thus he broke them
down to adams in end game after his past
version found out that the avengers had
taken the stones back he decided to
completely erase all life and this may
have been to set everything back to
square one so that it would be millennia
before any more celestials could
possibly emerge he also worry that if
half of the people remain behind that
they try and bring the other half back
which if he got rid of everyone this
would just completely negate the chances
of now if they do reveal that thanos
actually knew about everything then i
think it's hinting towards a big
celestials versus eternals battle that
could be coming down the line clearly
they're gonna keep manipulating the
eternals into helping planets be
destroyed so it makes sense that they
would all rebel against them like the
ones on it this would lead to a massive
conflict that i think is the direction
that things could be heading we've seen
through the nowhere ahead that it is
possible for celestials to die and
potentially we will learn that this may
have been carried out by an eternal like
eros thanos now another potential theory
i've seen comes from mariah carey over
at screen crush who said that the golden
orb we see eros carrying around could
have been the one that the eternals of
titan used to communicate with
potentially the prime eternal lair who
spoke to arashum died and then the rest
of the eternals never found out the
truth about the celestials creating new
solar systems upon the destruction of a
planet for all we know thanos may have
never learned this either and instead he
could view the celestials as parasites
that just take take take without giving
a thumbs up now ryan also pointed out
that in what if episode 2 that t'challa
managed to change thanos mind with a
conversation that could have potentially
been about this as thanos is all about
balance perhaps to charlotte revealed
that the celestials create new life upon
destroying a planet and thus he decided
to put an end to his plan now in summary
there's not any way to say for certain
whether thanos knew for definite or not
but i think if we look at all the
evidence then there are some things that
marvel can definitely use in the future
to say that he did they're great at
laying the groundwork for things and
should they need to down the line they
can give thanos mission more weight by
tying it into stopping the celestials
this would explain why titan is so
messed up why he didn't just double
resources and also why his brother is
looking for eternals rather than being
on a planet helping the birth process
continue though i doubt the studio had
this plan laid out when making infinity
war it actually seems like they're going
to be leaning towards it and i do think
at some point we will learn that thanos
actually knew about everything which is
why he carried out the snap so if i had
to give a definitive answer i would say
yes than us did no and that we'll be
learning more about this in upcoming
films now obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on our theories so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of zack
snyder's cc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so if that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the eternals which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
the entire plot of the film the post
credits scenes and also talk about what
could be happening next time if not then
thanks for sitting through this video
i've been paul i hope to see you on the
next one take care peace